welcome back y'all many of you grew up
loving our next guest with his good
friend Keenan Thompson in shows like all
that and Keenan and Kell on Nickelodeon
as well as movies like good burger well
now they're back that's right good
burger 2 is out now and you can see it
on Paramount plus water I think so let
me
[Music]
see
oh yeah that's
water none for me
thanks they let to tell
m
I have to say new YK I know I love it
here so much the energy is so me I have
to ask though you had a health scare
recently which was crazy I did you're
good now right I'm good now but for a
minute you felt like you were like
paralyzed right was that what I yeah I
had a pinch nerve that like took out the
whole right side of my body and it was
like definitely a scare cuz it was like
oh this could be something worse but I
did MRI I did all of that and all I
could say is God is good I'm good I
clean all of
that the unknown is what freaks me out
the unknown I'm like what's happening in
there anyway so comedy as a kid like you
you who are your influences because
you're hilarious oh man Martin Lawrence
uh uh Richard prior uh John Ritter uh I
mean the list go on and on thre company
okay thre company yeah yeah yeah I love
yeah yeah man I love Martin Lawrence too
man that's
Lawrence is amazing yeah you see that a
lot in my comedy I was going to say yeah
you're just you're so funny and and
witty you and Keenan and I'm always like
what did y'all grow up on that you ended
up just morphing into these beings that
make people laugh everywhere you go yeah
also my family too and the people around
me in Chicago you know a lot of my
characters are based on that like even
one of my coaches did they hate that or
love that oh well I had a coach that was
like after me cuz I I had a character
called coach cedon and it was based on a
coach in Chicago and he was just mean
all the time it could
Valentine's and he be like I don't care
about no love sit down shut up you know
that he was loud like that you I had a
coach like that yeah I know what's wrong
with you yeah yeah you're feeling sad
they're like run it'll make you feel
better no it won't it will not actually
I hear another one of your influences
though was George Clinton right George
oh come on now Parliament Funkadelic
yeah you know what I mean oh
hey and um my dad had all the records he
had like a little you know man cave in
the basement in Chicago and uh he had
all those records and I would listen to
all of them and then in gilberger one I
got to meet George Clinton and you know
do the big dance scene uh and he's in
part two too yeah yeah we got him back
had back he's a good burger too yeah do
y'all improvise a lot I feel like cuz
Keenan what you'all got to be used to it
at this point you've known you've had
such a relationship established for so
long do you improvise a ton a ton and
then we we're using the same writers
from the first one so they know that
we're going to improvise and so we do
that all the time uh I look at
our first day of Good Burger too it was
super super funny cuz Keenan just kept
laughing with me with the wig on like he
could take cuz we've been around each
other with the beards and everything and
he's just look he can't take it we laugh
through the whole thing can't take it
seriously it was the longest first day
ever cuz we just kept cracking up and
every time I said anything it was just
he like nope can't take it NOP I can't
take it look at how K's looks do people
do you look
ridiculous do people ask y'all to rate
their burgers yes all the time imagine I
am the Burger King okay you know the
original original the original BK yeah
when we go anywhere five star driveth
through whatever they're like give us
free burgers that's amazing they give
you free burgers what a great
life yeah look I'm look once a once a
poor kid always a poor kid 395 is always
acceptable yeah what's your favorite
burger place okay so you have one here
so this one I don't have a favorite here
so y'all got to tell me what's the
favorite one here but in La I wanted to
do something and give back we had uh
national food service day uh this past
September and I wanted to give back to
Mom and Pop uh you know places and
burger places and so I started
showcasing them on my social media uh
started rating them and also giving them
a good burger review and then I also
tipped the cashier in the front because
you know Ed is a cashier so I tipped
them and we went to over like 20
different spots in La yeah yeah this
been did you have a favorite yeah like
if I go anywhere where should I go okay
favorite I love them all cuz I want them
to get mad at me so I love them all but
it's one spot called billionaire Burger
Boys billionaire billionaire Burger Boys
and they have a lobster Burger a lobster
burger and the lobster just the tail
hanging out the burger like look look at
that tail out the burger look at that
down look it tastes so good y'all like
look that one lady like oh I don't know
about that I don't know about but it
it's good it looks intimidating but it's
it's really good it's really good smush
it down take a bite SM it down yeah it's
all about Jason's with you he clapped my
M was like yeah you know about it yes
down in Compton right yeah there you go
oh my gosh I just want mac and cheese
barbecue mac and cheese barbecue you do
know what's happen it oh I won it now um
let's take a quick commercial break be
sure to check out good burger to
streaming on Paramount
[Music]
[Applause]
Plus thank you
y'all have a great night I'm going
home